[Music]
and don't fall for it news Oh submitted
by yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo submitted
this mm-hmm
a woman's clothing company is now facing
a class-action lawsuit over allegations
of a pyramid scheme allegations do we
know this clothing company have you
heard of lularoe no no what is that nope
it's a legging company mmm sounds like a
knock up a Lululemon it does especially
if it's gonna be ladies - Oh Lulu lawmen
lularoe a uniformed company I wouldn't
want any of those that should look like
pajamas yeah no they're horrible they
look like they try to [ __ ] up our
perfect how do we make the worst looking
as lever Pig Peggy Bundy tights it does
I love Peggy Bundy and she would not
wear this you know that's true she looks
don't rush it is this you're the only
leopard print yeah and she looked
applied see this woman's face I'm
getting paid for this that [ __ ] is tacky
as [ __ ] yes this company the way their
company works is they get these people
to buy merchandise and then sell it to
other people is that like it's like that
but the reason why they're they're
accused of being a pyramid scheme is
because the majority of the income that
this company gets is from the people
buying the merchandise to sell Atari Oh
actual customers buying the clothes no
[ __ ] it looks like [ __ ] and is it
outrageous in price yes how much of a
pair of those spotted ugly green pants
Kostis because if they're trying to sell
retail price for a wholesale that's when
you know it's a pyramid scam like so for
example let's say I have a sunglass
company let's say the wholesale price
generally for these are like 10 cents
right but then I'm gonna start pyramid
scam and say hey David one dollar you go
out there and sell it for a dollar fifty
that's what they're doing they're trying
to convince a lot of
people that are buying the merchandise
to just max out their credit cards even
sell breast milk to afford how do you
even convince someone with these clothes
how do you jump from credit card to
breast milk I don't know the gap in this
one mentor that's in the pamphlet know I
could sell breast milk so part of the
job training yeah I guess what you asked
for
well let me talk about your money maker
so there's Bob and SAP right there yeah
so there was this one mentor of a
company they did this video and in this
video they were talking about how they
met this woman and this woman was saying
like you know she didn't want to go into
debt and she couldn't afford paying for
the inventory out of her own pocket so
she decided like oh I can sell my breast
milk to the NICU departments like in
hospitals to help babies and so she was
there saying in this video like she was
so happy so excited she could sell her
breast milk and looking up money to buy
inventory oh my [ __ ] a lot of these
people like these women that are buying
inventory they're required early they're
encouraged to keep about 20 thousand
dollars worth of inventory oh my Wow
that's the major issue right there it's
bad enough yep yeah they're saying like
have at least ten items in every size
and all styles and that's the magic
number I just the worst idea when you
ever have like selling anything in
wholesale you don't do that what the
[ __ ] you don't buy even amounts of each
size never yeah wouldn't know [ __ ] their
favorite phrase is buy more sell more oh
that's original that's not that's Korean
itself bad more sedima yeah they're
getting pretty clever though because
they're not gonna get in trouble by the
law because the definition of a pyramid
scam is when you get money off of
recruiting and so like let's say if I
created a pyramid scam and I said hey
we're selling supplements this is a
fitness company but the way you join and
you can start selling is you pay me a
thousand dollars and then you can start
selling our product right what would
that be the same as buying inventory
4000 oh no that's just a joining fee you
can't have a joining fee that's what's
illegal I
think if that becomes your main income
so if you're selling way more joining
fees than you are supplements that's
that's kind of like the pyramids always
dispute that
okay USA say it's adjoining either
people are joining but the whole goal is
do they get twenty thousand dollars that
they have to buy off us to sell these
things so that that's not what we're
aiming at they could lie yeah that's
what's happening now they're kind of
changing it cuz back in a day they were
just selling membership to pyramid scams
yeah so it was like don't you want to be
a part of what we're doing yeah it's
like what are you really doing we're
we're selling Internet services yeah and
then people would just pay money I I was
a part of one in 2000 and I swear to god
it's one of those things where you know
it's kind of a pyramid scheme but you
you [ __ ] hope to god it's really not
a pyramid scheme and you don't know
jack-shit
I was like 18 at the time and then you
don't know anything about business you
see a bunch of people in suits you see
nice cars and then they start teaching
you how to become a businessman a sales
man and in there targeting people who
have no frickin idea what it takes to
run a bit launching like dynasty in the
morning they do that thing where they
wait did you go to like a seminar and
then they have all the rich people and
yes as I went to one of those and they
didn't [ __ ] know that I was lazy as
hell
so I [ __ ] went this is amazing but
[ __ ] that I'm lazy I went home and do
[ __ ] yeah and like for this company
they're targeting mom's expansion you
couldn't have your own business never
leave your kids you can do this all from
home and so that's pretty shady but then
another shady thing about this company
is that their initial policy allowed its
sellers to return merchandise for ninety
percent of its value not including
shipping
so the initial policy and then in April
of this year they changed the policy
where they would take back any unused
inventory for 100% refund plus shipping
cost but then all of a sudden in
September without telling anyone they
changed it back to the initial policy of
only 90 percent and then also they're
also they're telling a lot of these
sellers that want to give their
inventory back they're saying oh this is
it like this has been used and we
return it and since you're returning it
you're not allowed to sell it either so
now these people are just stuck with all
these merchandise that they can't even
resell either these are dirty people
yeah these people need to go to hell so
there's a class action suit happening
right now they still use the same
[ __ ] pitch to want to make full-time
income on a part-time basis guarantee as
soon as you [ __ ] hear that [ __ ] it's
a pyramid scam that's the life though
man I'm too lazy so I'm not the target
I make full-time income on an overtime
basis like that's what it is we had we
had a friend
mium bar where I don't know where he is
now but he was always joining a
different pyramid scam he he swore this
one was the one and it's like within the
friendship that we had he probably
joined at least six she does that too
we're all trying to beat the system like
David we all want to be as lazy as [ __ ]
and somehow make money doing it that is
the goal in life yeah but some people
just can't separate the [ __ ] from
like yeah it's hard
I remember selling water purifiers I
could [ __ ] sell anything like 20
water purifiers in this guy and whatever
I sell I get a piece of and I didn't
sell one [ __ ] thing hey 20 water
purifiers in my [ __ ] living room I
was miserable but I went for it yeah
they don't want to get rich fast yeah
that's true that sounds like a pureed
scarce water in town
I don't need to come back you didn't
take them back either oh [ __ ]
how much for one of those things back in
19 well now this is like in the 90s is
probably like 35 40 bucks 40 40 bucks
for it was like one of these little what
yeah he's like pre brittle water-filled
yeah exactly
that's like a couple hundred today I'd
say like my below is one for a energy
drink Oh a sell online and they just
gave you a free case I just hit the free
case and went home like I said they
drank it all this is awesome yeah they
didn't [ __ ] account for me being lazy
you know what the cool thing was is when
I joined the pyramid scam my friend's
brother was one of the top guys in
and he actually just told me like I
don't want you to be taken advantage of
and think that this is something else
than what it is they're like knots it's
a pyramid scam and there's like so if
you still want to be a part of it you
want to get your money back this is what
you do
he gave me exact kind of techniques and
they teach you pretty much manipulation
and brainwashing techniques that are
super cultish and what you think you're
doing is is a you're you think you're
you're just doing business so what
they're teaching these people they don't
know [ __ ] but they're preying upon
friends and family people know but these
people don't know like what you're doing
is really you're converting your friends
and family to just give money to this to
this group and it ruins your friendships
too because I mean when you start
selling [ __ ] like buy this ugly dress is
this great look at this the polka dots
buy it and then your friends go oh my
god now she just wants then you lose
your friends you lose reliably hood
you're being scammed you know it's a
cult acht it's a cult just be an
unmotivated human being that [ __ ] does
not affect you at all yeah that's true
cuz I had a real unmotivated friend that
I try to get it to this [ __ ] and he was
just staring at us like nah I just got
the free drinks and I left and I was
pretty good even in the whole like the
whole spiel about don't you want to like
provide for your parents when your
parents retire which is good because
they got the emotional heartstrings but
laziness just you know what we call you
a sea urchin
what is that so we had different names
for different types of individuals and
once you can identify what people value
then you can really really jump on that
and try to bring them in so there's
dolphins those are the type of people
who don't care about money but they care
about social stuff they like to party
and if the way you get a dolphin is hey
come on let's go hang out let's do this
let's party and that's why they have
these conventions with like you know DJs
and they make it funny to appeal to
those people right and then you got the
Sharks who are like they love money and
then so you could just tell them
straight up yeah you can make a lot of
money
look at this Dodge Viper look at this
land
geenie and then there's two more but I
forgot but the sea urchin is the bitter
unmotivated person doesn't give a [ __ ]
and you just you just go this was a sea
urchin
don't [ __ ] waste time on them let's
go we had up now he had a personal
somebody that we knew that got into some
cultish activity and I was highly upset
that he never approached me he probably
identified it that's a [ __ ] Archon I
[ __ ] went on that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] because the fact that he looked
at me and he was like that pulls a piece
of [ __ ] I was waiting for my cold call
cuz because everybody got a phone call
right but how's your life doing like
don't you want more never called me
never I'm waiting I waited for a whole
month I never got the coffee call like
you want to go for coffee you never got
it still waiting hello guys I hope you
guys enjoy the video please remember to
give us a big thumbs up and a like like
like and also when you guys sign on
YouTube make sure just kidding news is
the first thing you watch every single
day because we post videos every day ok
for more videos
[Music]